voilà c'est là c'est la maison là bas tu
vois au bout du champ c'est vrai que
même si ça fait quand même un certain
nombre d'années c'est vrai que moi je me
rappelle bien des lieux ça paraissait
beaucoup plus ça me paraissait beaucoup
plus grand dans mes souvenirs mais je
pense otelli aussi à la jolie dame en
moi je me rappelle bien même en arriver
au camp avec mes parents et de ce prêtre
qui nous accueillent ici
nous sommes à arthez d'asson au pied des
pyrénées
philippe qu'autant et olivier savignac
ont passé un été ici il y à 23 ans une
colonie de vacances pour jeunes
chrétiens des enfants venus de toute la
france et un prêtre arrivée d'orléans il
était vraiment dans la dans la posture
de séduction il a commencé à me parler
d'informatique ce commencé à
m'intéresser l'informatique tout ce
genre ce genre de choses et donc il est
vraiment dans un comportement de
séduction et je me suis pas senti en
danger du tout sur le moment
donc en fait ici c'était toute la partie
dortoir bungalows au coeur de la forêt
un peu plus loin près du stade de foot
c'était les tentes puisque ont été
divisés en deux groupes certains quitter
dans les bungalows et les autres qui
étaient sous tentes près la rivière
aujourd'hui le lieu est devenu une
propriété privée donc plusieurs petits
bungalows et moi je me souviens que mon
équipe nous étions sur le bungalow de du
fonds voilà
[Musique]
on
lorsque mes parents sont partis du camp
il m'a demandé de venir dans son bureau
donc c'était une petite pièce d'environ
12 mètres carrés où il y avait un bureau
en face la porte et à droite un lit un
lit simple et du cou d'abord il m'a fait
asseoir qu on a discuté avant que ils ne
me disent lui a été bien tu as eu
quelques petites opérations au niveau du
bas ventre
est ce que tu voudrais pas s'allonger
sur lady g un premier cycle de médecine
je vais voir si tout est bien rentré
dans l'ordre et donc c'est pour ça que
m'a convié à m'asseoir d'avoir sur
l'ebit avant de m'allonger quitté le
pantalon et le spip et il s'est mis à
inspecter les parties génitales
olivier était âgé de 13 ans philippe en
avait 12
il affirme lui aussi avoir été victime
de ces attouchements
selon différents témoignages au total
une dizaine d'enfants auraient été
agressées des agressions dont voici le
suspect le père pierre de casteau les
le prêtre du diocèse d'orléans a été
mise en examen en 2012 dix neuf ans
après ce mois de juillet dans les
pyrénées
à cette époque pourtant tout le monde
aurait été au courant des événements
je crois que ce qui m'a marqué beaucoup
c'est la peur des animateurs qui sont
venus me voir ils étaient eux-mêmes
effrayer voire paniqués
sachant que c'était le directeur du camp
qui avait commis ces actes
nous avons retrouvé l'une des
animatrices du camp anne geiger
travaillait à l'époque pour le mej le
mouvement eucharistique des jeunes
organisateurs de ces colonies de
vacances chrétienne elle nous raconte qu
un aumônier du mej a été dépêché sur
place depuis paris le jésuite aurait
alors organisé une confrontation ce
prêtre pourquoi chez les enfants il
avait touché les enfants alors que
c'était censé être une simple visite de
formalités un an qu'il avait le droit
aucun contact de toute façon est en fait
s'ils voulaient c'était assez éprouvant
un mois j'avais 18 ans 19 ans et c'était
quand même après être un homme d'église
avec un col blanc
c'était une autorité dans le coin donc
c'était un moment très difficile
est-ce que vous avez été témoin vous
même de ces agressions un petit garçon
avait s'était fait masser était blessé
et moi j'ai appris qu'il avait donc été
accompagnés par les prêtres et donc j'ai
tout de suite j'ai monté les escaliers
très rapidement j'ai volontairement
appelé et je suis rentré dans cette
pièce sans frapper un et j'ai trouvé ce
petit garçon allongée sur un matelas en
flip et ce prêtre sur un genou y ait en
fait face à cet enfant est toujours
pensé que j'étais j'ai bien sûr je pense
que j'ai permis d'éviter le cliché à ce
moment là mais je donc je suis arrivé
quelques secondes avant
[Musique]
ks suh le diocèse d'orléans des
événements d'arthez d'asson en 23 ans
quatre prélats se sont succédé à
l'évêché le premier et rené lucien
piquant des selon nos informations il
aurait été alerté en 1995 une lettre
envoyée par une orléanaise
elle y accuse le père de cast lead
d'attouchements sur son fils des faits
qui auraient eu lieu deux ans après
arthez d'asson
vient ensuite un deuxième évêque gérard
daucourt candas puis andré fort andré
fort qui recevra en 2010 cette lettre
d'olivier savignac je vous adresse ce
courrier pour vous faire part de faits
graves qui concerne un prêtre de votre
diocèse
andré faure aurait alors promis des
mesures conservatoires à l'encontre de
pierre de castelet mme lévesque ne fera
aucun signalement à la justice
aujourd'hui mis en cause pour son
silence
andré fort a été placé sous le statut de
témoin assisté
son avocat n'a pas souhaité nous
répondre
le 18 avril dernier coup de théâtre
jacques blaquart évêque d'orléans depuis
2010 révèle à la presse l'existence de
la faire en 2011
donc je reçois une victime
et donc à ce moment-là je décide de
prévenir la justice donc pour un prêtre
de nos diocèses qui avait commis dans
des actes pédophiles dans un camp dans
les années 90 et aujourd'hui donc il est
il est retiré de tout ministère j'ai
décidé de lui retirer au ministère
malgré sa mise en examen en 2012 pierre
de castelet et donc rester prêtres
durant quatre ans il a officié jusqu'en
mars 2016
ici dans cette église de l'est du loiret
on trouve encore son nom sur le dernier
bulletin paroissial
son avocate n'a jamais donné suite à nos
demandes d'interview
olivier philippe vivent aujourd'hui en
midi pyrénées nous les retrouvons à
toulouse tous les deux se bat depuis
plusieurs années pour que la vérité soit
faite sur un coup de tête philippe a
même écrit une lettre au père de
castelet en 2007 une lettre demeurée
sans réponse est de commencer comme ça
monsieur père de castelet vous souvenez
vous d'un camp mais ge arthez d'asson en
j'avais 12 ans à cette époque et pour ma
part je n'ai jamais eu la chance
d'oublier ce qui s'est passé durant ce
camp il ya quelques mois alors que
j'avançais dans ma vie se souvenir à vos
revenus
une nouvelle fois nantes et j'ai eu
quelques manières déboires socio
affectif
pour faire simple et puis et puis donc
son revenu un peu comme des com
comme des des flashs quelques images
ça vient une première image qu une des
images c'est comme une espèce de
fantômes un petit veau en deux temps en
temps ça revient vous savez pas trop
pourquoi
des souvenirs douloureux et de la colère
la colère d'apprendre que leur agresseur
présumé a sans doute continuer à côtoyer
des enfants
après quelques recherches je découvre
qu'il est vicaire épiscopal travaillant
toujours auprès de jeunes et notamment
avec le mouvement scouts d'europe dont
il est aumônier diocésain en faisant ses
recherches
olivier tombe également sur cet article
il relate une formation à destination
des prêtres pour lutter contre la
pédophilie
elle a eu lieu dans le loiret au mois de
mai 2011 une formation durant laquelle
pierre de castelet est intervenant le
lien a depuis été supprimée d'internet
je crois que cette personne avait un
rôle important au sein du diocèse
d'orléans il était vicaire épiscopal en
charge de plusieurs dossiers de
plusieurs services c'était quelqu'un de
très intelligent
je crois que à l'époque les responsables
et du mouvement qu'aristide des jeunes
et du diocèse d'orléans n'ont pas pris
conscience de ce qui était réellement
voilà une agression sur mineure
[Musique]
olivier et philippe sont représentées
par deux avocats du barreau parisien
pour eux c'est clair l'omerta a été
organisée par certains responsables du
diocèse pour moi je l'interprète comme
une loi du silence
c'est à dire que on a l'impression que
on veut gérer en interne
des faits dont on a connaissance
comme si c'était du ressort d'un évêché
d'un diocèse d'un évêque qu'il soit que
de traiter des affaires qui sont de
nature judiciaire
il ya un texte qui est très claire dans
code pénal qui réprime la non
dénonciation d'atteintes sexuelles sur
mineur de 15 ans on ne gère pas quand on
est avec les choses ainsi on fait pas en
sorte de trouver des solutions des
mesures conservatoires quelconque
le texte est très clair le silence de
l'autorité ecclésiale mais aussi la
lenteur de la justice
ses avocats ont l'impression que la
sphère n'est pas considérée comme
prioritaire
l'instruction dure depuis plus de quatre
ans on déplore l'impression que
l'autorité judiciaire n'est pas du tout
pressé de faire la part de vérité de
cette affaire est que lorsque l'on
demande à auditionner tel ou tel pour
essayer de comprendre s'il ya d'autres
victimes
cela ne se fait pas et lorsqu'il y à des
investigations à entreprendre pour
identifier d'autres victimes
que ce soit au niveau du mouvement
eucharistique des jeunes ou au niveau du
mouvement scouts d'europe auprès duquel
se prêtera était particulièrement proche
et bien c'est démarche d'identification
d'autres victimes potentielles ne sont
pas réalisés aujourd'hui olivier et
philippe s'interroge le prêtre d'orléans
at il fait d'autres victimes ces vingt
dernières années
[Musique]
ce qui est douloureux je crois
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir que encore
des gens qui n'ont pas pu parler et
qu'ils gardent ça ne c'est surtout ça
pour moi je crois que j'ai évacué avec
le temps on peut appeler ça une
résilience j'ai évacué ce traumatisme
maintenant on va aller plus loin je veux
aller plus loin c'est vrai que quelque
part je pensais avoir vraiment tourné la
page et puis finalement je me rends
compte que le fait d'être connu
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important pour vraiment avancé
totalement et puis et puis derrière
aussi ce que j'espère c'est que on a le
bénéfice du doute si on peut dire mais
s'il ya des victimes en tout cas
qu'elles puissent se manifester qu'ils
aient le courage aussi aujourd'hui de
pouvoir elle même affronter cette
situation pour pouvoir mieux la dépasser
une troisième victime présumée est déjà
sorti du silence à strasbourg
olivier et philippe espère que d'autres
en feront autant
ils viennent de créer une association
sur le modèle des victimes présumées du
diocèse de lyon
notre parole aussi libéré j'espère pour
la suite que notre parole soit libéré
certes mais qu'elle soit entendue et je
crois que ça va passer par la justice
qui va faire son travail
ce procès que nous attendons mais
surtout aussi ne pas jeter l'opprobre
sur l'église parce que ça concerne
certains responsables certaines
personnes n'est pas toute l'église et ça
n'ouvre on vraiment faire passer le
message
[Musique]
à 36 ans olivier est célibataire
il est toujours croyants et pratiquants
tout comme philippe qui a fondé une
famille deux hommes deux fois qu'ils
espèrent désormais que justice se fasse
rapidement